des tours à bureau dont les étages sont
illuminés la nuit même s'il n'y a à peu
près personne à l'intérieur ou encore le
pont Jacques-Cartier et le Mas du Stade
olympique éclairé ce sont des scènes qui
nous émerveillent mais faut-il revoir
notre utilisation d'énergie c'est
certain que dans le secteur commercial
les tours bureau les concessionnaires
les centres d'achats qui ont des
lumières allumées 24 heures sur 24 il y
a des progrès qui pourraient être faits
le coût de l'électricité est assez
faible alors ça ne n'incite pas les
gestionnaires à mettre des systèmes
automatiques pour fermer les lumières au
Québec en 2019 34% de la consommation
d'énergie est attribuable au secteur
industriel suivi des bâtiments
résidentiels et commerciales avec 32%.
et du transport qui représente 28%.
c'est certain que il faudrait viser une
plus grande sobriété énergétique parce
que les Nord-Américains et les Québécois
utilisent environ deux fois plus
d'énergie par personne que les européen
et ce niveau de consommation n'est pas
vraiment compatible avec nos objectifs
de réduction des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre alors que cette tobriété
est forcée en Europe avec la crise du
gaz certains estiment qu'on est à des
années lumières de ce concept au Québec
on a gaspille parce que on produit une
électricité qui est abordable à faible
coût on a une un système très robuste
qui sera presque partout dans toutes les
régions du Québec
c'est une électricité qui est propre qui
provient de l'hydroélectricité la
consommation d'électricité atteint des
pics l'hiver notamment avec le chauffage
et les décorations de Noël il y a
pourtant des façons de la réduire 12
mois par année sans trop sacrifier tout
ce qui est choix d'électroménager pour
choisir évidemment des appareils qui
consomment moins qui sont certifiés
également toute la question de par
exemple ne pas prendre ces deux choses
hors de pointe et les grandes villes
québécoises peuvent comme en Europe
imposer des règles et interdire par
exemple la publicité lumineuse la nuit
ici mais le mieux Radio-Canada Montréal